55% of women said that listening to Joe
Rogan was a red flag 41% of men said the
same for a woman being into astrology
here's the thing right 35% of men said
that a woman listening to Joe Rogan was
a red flag but a man listening to Joe
Rogan and a woman listening to Joe Rogan
is not the same thing that's true too
I've heard this just speaking with young
guys that they are to some extent sort
of bothered by these gender differences
in politics and how more and more young
women are sort of identifying in a more
sort of sharp leftwing Direction because
you have to be to some degree
psychologically peculiar if you're a
young woman who is a sort of rightwing
person because you're sort of going
against the grain